so a lot of people on the internet are
upset about Joe coming out and saying
that he's buying corona tests for all of
his guests every time they enter the
studio to do a podcast what they're
upset because they're saying that there
are a lot of people who can't get tests
done and are suffering while he can just
buy it out of his own pocket so it's
important for people to realize number
one it's so much cheaper than people
think it is $200 let's turn it on test
is like 200 and change for everybody so
well no for 1% for him to come I think
it's it's a one-time thing right I don't
think it costs too much jeweler ology
test yeah it's not what I heard was $200
total because the actual yeah be killed
so they came to my house yeah but
they'll test your family for 200 really
yeah he's an extravagant that's a lot of
money a lot of money a lot of money but
it's not extravagant it's not here's the
thing there's a number you can call
it'll come to anybody South yeah not
only that it's not like Joe Rogan is
taking a test away from it he chose
being very very responsible he can't
afford it and the reason he can afford
is cuz he's earned it because people
love his podcast it's also called teller
he's put in 10,000 hours he's put in way
more than that Joe's been also are you
enjoying his content yeah the the pride
12 hours content content he gives you
cool that he gives you for free
cool oh you're talking about the biggest
show in the world yeah and the guy wants
get tested yeah you know initially he
tests HEDIS Barry being responsible
tests all his guests so he's setting an
example in that sense also it's not his
fault that not everybody can afford that
our issues with the government yoshi's
with your local yeah you know
representatives not Joe Rogan right
and I'll say anyone who's upset suck a
dick right how about that right there
you go people are also saying that I
believe it was the doctor who's
administrating these tests for Joe he
came out and said that they're doing the
blood work not the nasal passage and so
the same guy so he did all of us so he
pricked your finger like you're taking a
you know blood sugar test if you have
diabetes a pretty stringer you drop the
blood
this little thing he puts into this
little cartridge yeah and he said that
that test actually isn't fda-approved
and so he would it wouldn't really make
sense for people to be angry about Joe
taking away testing from other people
whereas if you go to the hospital the
nasal one is actually FDA approved and
that's the one that the hospital would
have to administer not the blood test
yeah that's how I take all the way how
about this goes every test program pays
for including the ones that that his
guests take should he instead use that
money to provide for tests of the public
not Joe's that's nice it's nice
responsibilities responsibilities size
responsibilities so he imagine being
upset by this yeah it's a non-event it's
like honestly no one successful who's
upset about them just can't get it
together take care of yourself yeah some
people just need something to be upset
about that's not what it is tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]